ich weiß nicht wann ich die schaufel gut
sie gut
[Musik]
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu epic skyrama
pathetischen irgendwie sowas ganz genaue
eingabe hde was genau wir machen hier
weiter wir sind jetzt hier mittlerweile
so weit wollte ich gar nicht
angeschlagen habe in einer anderen folge
nur weil du immer so extrem geträumt
wurde star stadtentwickler musst du
nicht eine aggression an mir auslassen
in der letzten folge statt sehr heftig
mit den ganzen krieg mann und meinen
fällaktion da steht jetzt eigentlich
wir haben auf jeden fall noch weiter
übrig für uns was steht hier noch ich
hab's gar nicht gelesen wir uns einfach
weiter gesprungen
also hier steht der must be something
wrong erkennt meldet er bei mir stand
einfach nur so viele blumen hier ja sehr
wichtige nachricht also da stand gerade
hier ist irgendetwas falsch er kann es
riechen wollen wahrscheinlich alles an
gilt eine nett also keine ahnung ich
guck mal ganz kurz probiert angeht ich
weiß gar nicht ob ich überhaupt richtig
ja hier geht es nach denke schon
jetzt ging wieder sein wasser dingsbums
können aber nicht ein
nach dem download ist wie eine kiste aha
hier ist toll you found die batterie
wieder geträumt von dir und freundlich
vorschlagen wird so schnell nicht wir
müssten zu bayern ja ich glaube wir
müssen an das geht relativ schnell gut
ich bin oben
ja ich auch monat herunter ich hab gar
keine sprung verstärken mit auf werden
dann wird er ich gleich erstmal mit zum
trank abwerfen
ich warte hier schon wie auf die kripo
die gleich bestimmt hier werden den
hausbau und definitiv die kommen gleich
wieder aus allen ecken rauhaardackel
daniel wall street nur kurz lässt auch
ihre freundin robert fischer ja herrlich
einen kindergarten mit sprung
verstärkung die karten macht schon
eigentlich spaß die tat also
downloadlink und so alles natürlich in
der beschreibung wie immer eigentlich ja
du hast wiedereinstand verstärkung
things genau kommt trotzdem nicht hoch
haha ich habe auch nicht gewusst warte
mal sprung verstärkung 22 ich hab da
haben wir ja hier lagen hier lang hier
vorne erste leiter
das einliter okay hier sagen und wird
ein mega sprung darüber und dann noch
ein mega spucken darüber ein und dann
runter fallen
als ich probier's mal so ich bin darauf
habe es geschafft bin nach vorne bei in
seiner kiste
jetzt ist wieder sprung verstärkung
street drin also ich habe davon langsam
echt ziemlich viele
ich habe davon auch mal richtung vor
vier stück keine ahnung
und ich schaffe das ach ich hab gar kein
sprung verstärkung also ich hab das ja
ich komme dabei wartet einen moment da
hinten es geschafft er den letzten
sprung ich glaube nicht doch ich habe
ihn geschafft auch erstmal eine
werbeunterbrechung zu genau wie ich bin
jetzt mal hier check point hey ich habs
geschafft
perfekt von check point geht dann aber
shader grad ausgemacht dann sieht das
ganze hier eigentlich zwar nicht so geil
aus aber es läuft mir deutlich flüssiger
und das ist auf jeden fall das
wichtigste hier erstmal erst recht bei
sprüngen immer genau so hier lange okay
hier ist also ein pilz gang ich weiß
nicht schaffen wir das wie hier habe ich
noch vier minuten das doch wir schaffen
das nein aber ich lebe noch aber wir
hatten einen checkpoint glaube ich ja
genau das ja nicht einfach wieder hoch
okay ich schaffe ich das und ich schaffe
das wunderbar
ich bin auf dem weg ich es mir dass man
diese mutter brauche ich okay okay hier
muss man mit leitern ohne leiter sprünge
ich hasse die leiter sprünge kann ich
überhaupt nicht ja leider springt so um
block hohmann leiter oder so das ist
schrecklich ist das finde ich auch
und ich muss geschafft perfekt okay ich
habe es auch geschafft er ist schafft er
es den sprit problem das schaffen
eigentlich immer ein paar geschäft
gedrückt halten dann um die ecken
das schafft man eigentlich immer erwarte
ich komme runter kommen erst mal genauer
an bei der who
du weißt ja ne pvp ist an soweit ich
schaffe das jetzt aber meinst du ich bin
lieber hoch wir wollen hier endlich hier
nicht hier
ok wo lang ich weiß nicht auf den baum
war weiß ich nicht was du da ihr sollen
irgendwelche dschungel tintenfische sein
aha irland gehört das ist ein dass nadal
an
ich habe ein buch gefunden bata und noch
ein post panzer kann es im august ans
ergeben dass da noch mehr ja ich gebe
dir welche meiner reise alleine reicht
von porsche auf dem blog wir werden eng
welche butter nicht finden auf jeden
fall stand auf den stand im buch
irgendwie bewusst der programms war sky
wurden feind ok tränke haben wir ja dass
kinder hast du noch den brustpanzer für
mich die toten auf den block und nimmst
du einfach wieder mit hier lag ich
übrigens an sondern sondern so ein
tolles kate bei der trick nummer 17
einfach hinter dem wasser fallen die
kleinen eingang machen genommen weg
wieder nicht da ist wieder so ein
komischer troll blog und da hätten wir
die finden phishing wie in der luft in
dem blog naja ich bin auf dem weg bist
du in den eingangs schon reingegangen
hinter dem wasserfall ja aber nicht okay
ich bin schon lange wieder ein tolles
leckeres stück butter müssen wir auf
jeden fall etwas haben müssten müssen
die zuschauer auf jeden fall mal
ausprobieren einfach so butter essen ist
sehr sehr lecker ja einfach jeden morgen
mein stück butter
das war knapp rein schlinge und dann
passt das schon alltag gerettet
logbücher und ende ganz ganz vielen
büchereien wastwater squid zuwachs
hätten hier trinkt ultrabooks weg li
voller passion cinerenta solche sprüche
mehr drin
we had used car steht hier brennt hat
hier ist eine die revanche h-milch
optimal da müssen wir alle unsere dings
reintun alle unsere burschen sind dann
nämlich trinken mit dem effekt weg ist
okay so was ist hier ist eine
baggerschaufel und einfach mal hier in
schönen einer milch unter schlägen auf
einmal wenn ich kekse backen nämlich
auch immer drei einmal milch milch
butter sofa ein sofa aus butter ok
angenehmen ist wieder ein checkpoint das
sehr schön
und jetzt einfach mal mainka zum von
euch hab stiefel gefunden jetzt beim
rauchen mit gut ich feiere ich komme
gleich vorbei was auch nicht nachfolge
sei schon vorbei ich stocke billig
kommen hinterher egal wo du bist
ich krieg dich noch an da bist du ja
[Musik]
kommst du nicht mehr raus geht
ich weiß nämlich die schaufel gut ist
sie gut brody ja ich will mal heftig
holen
alexander politthriller the ones verriet
kaktus james
du hast gut ich habe 100 gut tut gut
gold ein apfel sehr schön rüber kakteen
springe ich heiße das dass es auch ich
warte erstmal bis ich mein leben wieder
aufgeladen hat das auf jeden fall
erstmal so einen muss man nicht
irgendwie ich verstehe es nicht
ich glaube da muss direkt weiter
springen einfach wenn du darauf dass
nicht das geht auch nicht
ich hasse darüber kakteen springt weil
immer wenn du springen weltkriegs zu
schaden
ja ja ja ja ich könnte ja versuchen sich
da gleich bösen später ja noch immer
mehr zuspruch
ich fand die karte bis jetzt noch gar
nicht so schwer aber solche schaffen
werden dann schon schwieriger
let us know how sweet spot dem so dann
müssen wir die hoch wie hast du das
geschafft man ja du musst immer dreimal
warten ist mir aufgefallen drauf dreimal
schaden kriegen und dann mit ganz
schnell weiter springen dann nicht
erfasst viermal stand und auch wenn du
hier ankommst nämlich meine schafe und
punch dich eh wieder 20 41 33 nein nein
jetzt auch wieder fahrrad muss wissen
genau ich probiere es einfach mal ein
bisschen weiter zu kommen
auch nö aber wenn du darunter fällt das
treffen damit jetzt auch einen
checkpoint ja den habe ich dort geholt
ich denke das ist drei mal warten 23
jump nein ach ja ja ich bin ja kurz
kleine tipps 23 sport ist das 1 2 31
das sterbe ich doch ich bin jetzt schon
halbtot bedeute schon halbtot abkommt
wollen wir nicht lieber feierabend
machten 1 23 so wir sind gerade bei zehn
minuten
ich möchte mit feierabend nicht entweder
folge sondern eher jene kommen wir
lassen das rüber
wir haben genug futter heute schon
gegessen mutter gefunden also wir
brauchen nicht mehr genau
einst war ich doch das okay da sehe ich
hoffe ich hoffe sie schaffen
bitte stirb dass wir bis jetzt noch
yahoo
ok soll ich dich irgendwie hierhin holen
check point oder sony kann ich nicht
kommen ich war mein leben und ich ja mal
wieder auffüllen hatte zweimal das ist
gut und wir schauen jetzt einfach mal im
komm ich jetzt ein bisschen zu kaufen
sie heute noch den diamanten helm für
nur drei euro 99 in jedem süßwaren haben
waren und da läuft der etwa direkt
runter höchst professionell weißt du
bescheid
[Musik]
ok hab was kann man hier eigentlich
machen wenn manche hochklettert wat x
hey schaffe ich nicht mal das ist älter
da vital checkweigher 1 23 versuch's mal
zwei mal zu warten also draufgehen 12
und dann weiter
ich hoffe dass kein lehrer schaffen alle
mal den kommentar schreiben denkt er
schafft es genau jetzt und es ist zu
spät
ok jetzt ein abgeschlossener und er
schafft wieder nicht ich glaube die
quote das erschafft ist eine 1000 das
wäre ein eure setzt gericht 1000 euro
wieder raus dass jetzt diese folgen
ortschaft nein alter mein leben ist auch
schon wieder dauern
du hattest doch im goldenen apfel oder
ja ich glaube ich aber nicht der liegt
nicht da oben drauf oder wusste ich habe
noch ein hier
ok ja bestimmt
ich hab' ich habe keine ich hab ne
goldene karotten da war noch was du dich
also auch ich habe auch noch eine
schaufel ne das ist ihr bewusst aber
davon ist eine last sein okay passiert
nicht viel
ich glaube einfach mal ein bisschen
weiter mussten hier und da geht macht
daher weiter dass die beschäftigten
gesprochen hier gar nicht manchmal
mensch der nie schaffen steht da shift
nein
man werde nach halben leben ich war bei
dem letzten sprung ich hatte ein halbes
leben und da dachte ich schaffe ich
nicht und dann habe ich ihn noch nicht
kann ich ja wieder 1000 stunden warten
dass mein leben jetzt habe ich kaum
gegen patenten fische töten
ach meine güte
die karte war bis jetzt gerade eben noch
gar nicht schwer aber dann kamen die
kakteen und haben mich fertiggemacht
dann kam die böse
nein aber meine ich jetzt was geschafft
[ __ ] ehrlich gesagt so mancher
das ist so knappmann checkpoint frei
hier
okay gut den job muss ich jetzt schaffen
schon wieder nicht das ist so klug
ich kann ja schauen ob nicht wenn ich
lesen dass ihr vielleicht schaffe dann
kann ich ja eventuell dann irgendwie
hoch holen oder so ich schaffe das auch
noch jene also sehen wie gar nicht erst
die hoffnung auf also wie gesagt leute
können einfach in die kommentare
schreiben
dass diese folge schafft oder nicht ich
bin eher dafür dass er es nicht schafft
also ich bin natürlich dafür endlich
erfolge in einer minute beendet dann
schaffen wir das in 3 43 minuten
du schaffst das schon nur schon so schön
dann springe ich dazu war er head so
darf nicht schiff dabei gedrückthalten
glaube ich das ist der fehler eine
angewohnheit von den ganzen leid haben
uns noch so freundlich dass sprung muss
jetzt schon wieder nein ich bin
gestorben
wenn man halben leben wir beim letzten
sprung und ich bin hier am arsch der
welt hier auf dem regenbogen tunnel
wollt ihr mich verarschen heute aachen
spawn teleportieren da ein okay er
möchte so schaffen
ich schaffe das ich komme wieder ich
habe jetzt den sprung hier auch
geschafft und eventuell gar nicht hier
irgendwann check point holen
besonders sollte wirklich mich denken
wie teleportieren wenn ich nicht gleich
wer da bin
wenn man muss auf jeden fall schnell
machen geht nicht ich muss mich
teleportieren
ich wählte die sprung verstärkung ach ja
da machen wir einfach so bei so ich
würde sagen dass wir hier das so machen
dass einer sich drauf stellt der andere
spielt dann schon mal rüber springs
einfach rüber dann bleibe ich einfach
stehen
[Musik]
jo hat habe ich geschadet
da kommt darum jetzt muss er es in einem
durch schaffen
und du musst noch mal auf die tür auf er
habe es geschafft in die tür
nein weil ich probiere dort back and we
try
ich versuche erst mal den den lustig
dann musste ich kann auf jeden fall
schon mal direkt durchgehend du bist ja
natürlich der wimo dessen immer wieder
probieren muss die tür war ganz kurz
offen ist aber nicht nur offen
ich bin durch ok ich probier doch mal
eben schnell das schaffe ich auch noch
ihr in der folge auch noch
bio und und und und man dafür nicht
hingehört nur dass er zeigt ebenso ein
bild vor das war ein sehr großes bild
und da war einfach so ein like surf
gemälde und das muss ich ab schlagen mit
wir durchkommen oder werden halt einfach
durchgehen können und ich würde sagen
jetzt ist hier passt super
ja wir kriegen ja die folgende dritte
folge vorbei vierte folge bei gome hat
die bayernlb als auch die tatsächlich
einfach aus spaß hier gibt es
waffengesetz damit man solche nicht dann
halt nicht jeder solche bekommt ok also
ich habe bei mir zu hause auch so eine
schaufel mit um verstärkungen schlag die
nicht in seinem garten also ich finde
auf jeden fall sehr cool damit auch ja
da hast du die letzten folge bewährt
nicht vergessen und ciao ciao